roaming what is roaming remember those
days when on holiday in another european
country your mobile was not so useful
we've come quite a ways since then
today to roam like at home means a lot
of things like getting lost while
exploring new horizons and still being
able to share the experience
just sent you my gps coordinates
could you bring me my boots
it also means being able to document
your adventures abroad for your
followers without an astronomic phone
bill waiting for you back home
eu roaming rules enable us to call
text and surf the internet without extra
charges while staying in another eu
country exactly as we would at home but
with more interesting stuff to report
as these rules are about to expire the
eu is taking action to secure free
roaming for another 10 years with a few
extra perks
currently data roaming can be slower
future rules will ensure data services
keep up with fast-paced globetrotters
they will also ensure that you can reach
emergency numbers and service hotlines
without having to worry about hidden
charges because who knows when and where
you might need them well i guess i'll be
waiting here don't forget to send me
pictures if you enjoy our content make
sure you like our video and subscribe to
the digital eu channel
[Music]